شكرا لك وسيله ولكل مراسلي شبكه الجزيره
في تركيا في انقره في اسطنبول في ازمير
وغيرها اذا سنحاول الان وسيله وانتم
مشاهدينا ان نلقي نظره اخيره ربما على
نهايه هذا اليوم الانتخابي وان لم تكتمل
بعد نسبه مئه بالمئه
والسبب في ذلك ان بعض الاصوات ما زالت
تفرز فيما يتعلق
بالمنافذ الحدوديه والمنافذ الحدوديه
بمعنى اذا كان شخص
منتخب لكنه من طوكيو ويمر باحد المطارات
التركيه فيسمح له بان يصوت في هذا المطار
في صبيحه او في مطار ازمير او غيرها من
المطارات وبالتالي يحتاجون الى جمعها
والذهب بها الى مراكز معينه محدده لفرزها
وهذا الذي يؤخر انتهاء نسبه
المئه بالمئه بالنسبه لصناديق الاقتراع
ربما اذا اردنا ان نقرا الصوره الاخيره
للرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
مع حلفائه في تحالف الجمهور على الخرائط
التي نرجع للخريطه السابقه يا شباب فقط
حتى نفهم لماذا الرئيس التركي
استطاع ان ينهي هذه المناطق باللون
البرتقالي بهذا الشكل تحالف الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان ربما يعود له الفضل في
حسم كثير من المناطق لانه كان هناك توزيع
للمهام فيما يتعلق بالتركيز على الرسائل
لتحالف الجمهور التحالف الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان على كامل الخريطه نرى انه كان
هناك المكون الكردي ممثلا في هدى بار وهو
حزب اسلامي
محافظ ايضا حزب بطبيعه الحال الحزب الاكبر
في هذا التحالف الحركه القوميه وتاثيره
الكبير على وسط الاناضول ومنطقه البحر
الاسود وقلنا اكثر من مره نذكر بان سبع
مناطق رئيسيه منطقه البحر الاسود والمنطقه
الوسطى وسط الاناضول يسيطر عليها بالاضافه
الى التوجه المحافظ التوجه القومي وهنا
يفهم لماذا
ادخل الرئيس التركي حتى في الصوره الاخيره
بعد خطابه سنان اوغان في هذا التحالف لان
سنان اوران له قابليه وله حضور كبير في
وسط الوسط الحركه القوميه عموما وكان عضوا
في الحركه القوميه مع دوله باتشر بل تنافس
مع دوله باتشيلي على رئاسه
الحزب وبالتالي يمكن ان يفهم هذا هذه
الصوره الاخيره للرئيس التركي الذي وقف مع
انصاره بالاضافه الى الاحزاب الرفاه
الجديد اربكان فاتحه اربكان نظرا لانه في
اليمين المحافظ اذا تحالف الجمهور هو
تحالف يعتبر يمين ويمين وسط يمين محافظ
حتى العنصر الكردي فيه عنصر يعد محافظ
واسلامي على العكس من تحالف الشعب
الجمهوري الذي ضم المتناقضات وهو ما اثر
بشكل كبير على اصوات
يعني تحالف الشعب بقياده كمال كلجدار اولو
نجد من اقصى اقصى اليمين في اللحظات
الاخيره يتم ضمه في حين انه كان يرغب
كمالك الجدار في اصوات الاكراد الذين يمكن
وصف ان نسبه المشاركه بالاضافه الى الذين
لم يذهبوا للتصويت انخفضت نسبته في مناطق
الاكراد ولم يعمل هو شيء لزيادتها كان
اكتفى بدعم حزب الشعوب الديمقراطيه عن بعد
وهذا اثر كثير على نتيجه كمالك الجدار لكن
قبل حتى هذه الجوله كماله كان يحتاج الى
تقريبا مليونين ونصف ليقترب من اصوات
الرئيس التركي اردوغان في المرحله الاولى
في الجوله الاولى وثلاثه ملايين تقريبا
ليحسم السباق وهو فرق كبير الان مليونين
ومئتين الف صوت لصالح الرئيس التركي
مقاربه للفارق في الجوله الاولى اذا لم
يخدم تحالف الشعب او هذا
التكوين الغريب
لكم في تحالفه من دعمه بالاضافه الى ان
منطقه الوسط التي كان يعني يروج كماله بان
احمد داودول سيكون ممثلا للحركه القوميه
لانه من قونيا وقونيا في الوسط فيها خزان
انتخابي كبير لم يؤثر ذلك باي شكل من
الاشكال على اصوات كمالك في مناطق وسط
الاناضول ايضا اكرم امام اولو هو من
مواليد طرابزون وقام هو يعني معظم الحملات
الانتخابيه في الشمال التركي لم ينجح ايضا
في جلب اصوات كافيه لكم اذا ممكن من خلال
هذه الخريطه ان نفهم ان تحالف الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان والذي حرص على
ياخذ صوره تذكاريه معهم خطابه خطاب شرفه
النصر
يمثل بالفعل كيف تعامل تحالف الجمهور مع
الخريطه الانتخابيه وكيف تم توظيف كل عنصر
منها للوصول لهذه النتيجه بينما خذلت
الشعب كماله الجدار اولو لم يتمكن لا منار
مع كل الزخم بالنسبه لها في الحركه
القوميه لم تتمكن من رفع نسبه في مناطق
القوميين ولا داود اول في قونيا ولا
الاكراد حسموا السباق لصالحه رغم دعم حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطيه من الخارج اليسار
الاخضر كما يسمى الان ولا اوميت اوزداد
اقصى اقصى اليمين المتطرف الذي كان يهدد
بتهجير
اللاجئين اذا الحديث ان هذه الخريطه عاكست
حتى على الصوره الاخيره لكم القى خطابه
فريدا والقت منار اكشنار خطابها فريده
والحديث الان عن
لكثير من وسائل الاعلام التركيه المعارضه
تطالب حتى كما الاشجار اوغلو بعقد المؤتمر
الخاص بحزب الشعب الجمهوري لاعاده النظر
في رئاسته هذا هو مجمل ما حدث في جولتين
انتخابيتين يمكن القول بان الخريطه
الانتخابيه تشكلت بهذه الصوره رغم ان
الرئيس التركي لم يحسم الولايات الكبرى
فيها لكن الاستراتيجيه التي اتخذها في
العمل على كامل التراب التركي ادى الى هذه
النتائج ما لاحظناه اليوم ختاما ربما
ارتفاع نسبه الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان عن الجوله الاولى في مناطق الشمال
والوسط وحتى مناطق المتضرره من الزلزال
بواقع خمسه بالمئه وفي بعض الاحيان وكل
صوت يؤثر 8000 من اصوات سنان اون في
العموم في كل ولايه
ذهبت للرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ما
بين ثمانيه الى 12 الف في بعض الاماكن
كانت قادره على الحسم بينما في في عفوا في
انطاليا
واكثر من 100 الف صوت كانت لسينان اوغان
لكن لم تخدم كثيرا اردوغان في هذه المنطقه
لانها تاريخيا تذهب دائما لحزب الشعب
الجمهوري وبالتالي ذهبت لتحالف الشعب
الجمهوري لماذا ذكرت انطاليا لانها اكبر
منطقه حصل فيها سنان اوغن على اصوات
تجاوزت 100 الف ومع ذلك لم تكن خادمه بشكل
كبير لكنها خدمت في المناطق التي لها بعد
قومي اكثر بالنسبه لسنان اوغن وايضا
بالنسبه
للرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اضن من
المناطق التي نريد القاء الضوء عليها هي
المنطقه الوحيده من مناطق الزلزال
بالاضافه الى ديار بكر ذات البعد الكردي
لم تعد للرئيس التركي رجائي طيب اردوغان
والفرق ليس كبيرا بشكل كبير جدا لكن هناك
فرق تقريبا 110
كنا نركز عليها بعد فرز مئه بالمئه من
الاصوات ان سنان اوغان كان قد حصل على 7%
منها وهي كانت في 2018 ضمن المناطق
الولايات التي انتصر فيها اردوغان فهل كان
يمكن ان يستعيدها بفضل اصوات سنان اوغان
هذه من المناطق التي ارتفعت نسبه الرئيس
التركي فيها بشكل بسيط لكن الارتفاع كان
الاكبر وهنا يمكن ان يرجح في هذه المناطق
كان له تاثير على اصوات كمالك الجدار اولو
بنسبه بسيطه عن الجوله السابقه لكنها بقيت
كما هي عن الجوله السابقه لصالح كمالك
الجدار عندما نتحدث واردنا ان نستوعب
الوضع في المناطق الاكراد ولايه فان من
الولايات الرئيسيه الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان حصل فيها على مقعدين بالنسبه
لتحالفه مقابل ثلاث او اربعه مقاعد لحزب
الشعوب الديمقراطيه المسمى الان اليسار
الاخضر لا وجود لحزب الشعب الجمهوري الذي
يقوده كمالك الاجدار اوغلو في فان ذلك فاز
فيها كماله الجدار بواقع 61.50 لكن اقل من
الجوله السابقه بمعدل تقريبا 22 الف صوت
ذهبت معاني الجوله الاولى وهذا نمط متكرر
حتى في ديار بكر الان التي نستعرضها بشكل
نهائي رغم انه حصل فيها كماله على
71.61 وكان يتوقع ان ترتفع نسبه الاصوات
610 تقريبا اقل من الجوله السابقه بما
يعادل تقريبا 20,000 او حتى اكثر من ذلك
فاثرت عليه بشكل كبير وادت الى انه لا
يرفع من زخمه في هذه المناطق وبالتالي في
المجمل المنطقه التاليه هي منطقه امنيه
بدرجه كبيره هي هكاري هناك كثير من
الاشكاليات تتعلق بحسبه
الحزب يسمى في تركيا الحزب الارهابي اثرت
هذه المنطقه بشكل كبير ايضا على حظوظ كمال
كلجد هكاري لم يتمكن من حسمها وبطما ايضا
ربما لم يحصل فيها على ما كان يؤمله
انخفضت الاصوات عموما في مناطق الاكراد ما
بين عشرين الى ثلاثين الى 35 الف صوت في
المجمل كان هناك هبوط كبير واثر على حظوظ
كمالك الجدار